Chris Harris jr. while the television
audiences away first time two times I
say hello to you how are you sir good
man yes you are
sits for television only this is a
visual medium as opposed to the radio
simulcast what's up can we check out the
kicks on Harris jr. please baby what do
we have here sir some new booties man
2020 new version okay those are Gucci's
yeah like a training kind of I guess I
guess so I know by the way I appreciate
the laces matching the rest of them
would you would you take these I mean
yes but it's a little out of my price
bracket oh is that right they're pretty
expensive new style yeah I don't think
they came out with this style so is this
the conversion of the what they got
let's be modest on behalf of Chris how
much how much these I think they're
they're pushing the price is Right rules
closest without going over
can you can you can you get me some some
of the music here please
closest without going over Chris Harris
with the new 2020 without going overseas
like this without going over like $850
1250 TJ Jefferson do you want to want to
come in here in bit as well
850 1250 want to go $1.00 go $1.00 go
twelve fifteen fifty twelve fifty Wow
I'll go one dollar of one dollar well
how much the actual retail price is it's
twelve to twelve fifty you won't even
say but you said excuse me you don't win
you said you went on your private it's
probably more with the taxes
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow by the way I think everybody wear
size 12 so it's not very hard to find my
size impressive okay most people do very
good I mean I'm an 11 Chris if you just
want to loan those out there might be
cheaper with just regular laces laces
and maybe they broke more in your price
bracket back with Chris in a moment
the pride of Tulsa and Bixby Oklahoma by
way of Kansas now in his ninth season in
the NFL from the Denver Broncos and now
I guess of your free agent class of
defensive backs Chris Harris jr. good to
see you back here on the show sir doing
good man I have Oklahoma never come
knocking on your door
I had one offer at Kansas and that was
it that's it yeah who was the one who
offered you who was there at the time
and a no Mangino the man genno
canvassing me at basketball practice and
then offer me now imagine when Mangino
walks into a basketball gym it's this is
this is a no no no offense but what how
what would you play in the hoop score
you point guard yeah point guard your
point guard yeah
yeah I kind of run the show sex politics
foot 6 foot 511 511 more you're more
Isiah Thomas yeah I'm kind of like Chris
Potter Magga everybody involved still
can get a bucket and I still do do it
off speaking of which Chris Paul's
Oklahoma City Thunder is on fire oh yeah
right now do you root for the Oklahoma
City not Lakers on my team for sure
look I've always been like a fan even
says Kobe you got a no okay I'm just
need to do the math right here did oke
were you still in Oklahoma when when
Seattle sent the Thunder your life okay
that's see I was already a Lakers fan
the Thunder got there okay I kind of
joined Thunder - okay so Kobe's your guy
oh you have so grown up that's that's
your guy oh yeah Kobe oh yeah but do you
root for the Thunder now definitely yeah
I say Alexander I like him do real I
mean the last month
nobody's been hotter in the Western
Conference than the Oklahoma City
Thunder right now cuz Chris Paul he's
gonna organize a team make sure they
have a structure there won't be free
styling out there you know what I mean
so right there the the two point guard
combo guards that they're doing it's
kind of working out okay are you team
perk or team KD based on last night's
Twitter beef between I'm gonna go with
team KB because I think he made the
right decision for his career he need to
make he need to win a NBA championship
man that was the best platform ago let's
be honest here
you know I know you've enjoyed your time
at the Denver Broncos and you put your
time in there yeah but you know Chiefs
come knocking on your door and they give
you the right contract in the right spot
you're wearing red next year right I'm
listening everybody man listen everybody
and I mean Kansas I've been in school I
went to school there and so that's like
is another home for me too
yeah a lot of big following there so I'm
definitely looking at everybody man but
like you said I mean I don't see why
there wouldn't be a good fit so what do
you how are you I guess you're
approaching your free agent year this is
your first time you're a free agent -
right yeah nine years into your career
yeah and you have the hammer as to where
you want to go play yeah first time and
it's just just kind of be able to figure
out what's the best fit for me you know
best situation for me and what teams
really want me and so I'm interested and
decided to get that a me playing in
league nine years I got coaches all over
the NFL that coached me who I worked
with so I got a they know how they know
what type of person I am what type of
player I am so I think is gonna work out
very well is there any chance you could
go back to Denver yeah there's a chance
there is man we know that uh they
definitely definitely need corners there
so I definitely know I'm probably high
on their list for sure
so let me take my pen out and cross out
the get Krista trash away part of my
card right there look across that
that's not on my card I'm just drawing
lines where there was space man we
talked this year this year a lot man and
got a lot of communication from where I
was confused that doing what you're
confused during um just the whole
offseason man just seeing if they wanted
me things like that how I had to hold
out to try to I tried to get a long-term
deal here work out and so just trying to
see where the where the organization was
with me and it kind of cleared it up for
me so was there any part during the
Denver season where there was in the
locker room an offense defensive sort of
schism for them Vic Fangio his first
year there we actually didn't happen man
I actually did not happen I think
everybody on the team kind of gelled
pretty good man we didn't have a lot a
lot of fights or anything like that or
anything everybody gel together man and
you really don't see that from teams
losing teams you know there's usually a
lot a lot of fights and things like that
but coach Randy I was able to keep a
square um
offense was able I mean we had three
different quarterbacks this year so I
mean you can't have time to tip out man
we had a rally around those guys
well what about lock it looks like he's
got an it factor just from watching TV
yeah just from watching the way he plays
watching the way that he's mouthing the
lyrics whatever rap music's being played
up there in Denver what what about from
your perspective that's I think that's
like a fresher breath air for us man
that's something that we needed we've
been looking for that for I mean Super
Bowls four years ago five years ago now
so we've been looking for that man a
quarterback is gonna bring me energy
bring that spark for guys and he's done
that those last five games
hopefully he can just build on that
continuing approval and get better for
next year yeah cuz it he's gonna be your
starting quarterback in 2020 and yeah
Broncos area right I mean that how is he
how was he in the locker room how is he
he's great in the locker room man I mean
all the time he's always studying so I'm
always trying to give him tips from what
I see around did I played a lot of these
teams I know what they do on defense so
I always try to give him tips and things
like that and he takes some man he's
he's right there asking for all our
quarterbacks I like that so
I like the group that we had and they
just young man just got to get that
experience Chris Harris jr. here on the
richard.zito all right I'm going to turn
you into a member of the paparazzi right
now oh okay
the toughest team that you faced this
year that's still left in the playoffs
you face the Vikings you face the
Packers obviously week three was you
guys were still feeling your way in the
season
you faced the Titans you beat him but
Mariota was that that was that was when
they said we're going to Tannen a little
different team and then you just took
the tank Texans - yeah I mean you broke
him apart in Houston the toughest team
that you faced
where's which one cheese Casey I mean
their offense is dynamic they got the
players all over the field I just like
attracting me team you mean a four by
one team when you see those guys and you
know what with a big receiver tight in
Kelsey and I think they're hot right now
so whoever has to see those boys is
gonna be tough and sorry I'm riding with
them right now and that cuz you know
them your division of poly that's why I
even left him off the list right here
but oh yeah there's the top like out of
out of everybody oh yeah for defense to
go into a game and other than Lamar
Jackson's we didn't get to play him so I
don't and there's Aaron Rodgers you had
their offensive most complicated as the
Chiefs you know what I mean the cheese
do so much formation so many more
emotions it's in the Packers are the
kind of stagnant team or standstill type
of offense compared to the cheese okay
they keep you moving man so you always
got to be aware of different formations
things like that when you play case and
there he's just you know one of the
moments of the year Damian Williams is
just busting one straight up the gun oh
yeah I mean they start around the ball
it's over well but he's not to be no
one's catching him but Tyreke he'll ran
him down he's older when I came I think
cuz I think Tyreke was saying after the
game that Damian Williams always says
he's the fastest on the team that was
Tyreke he knows in the game to let him
know who's fastest what is it like
trying to cover him I don't know why he
thinks he's the fastest on her team I
mean Tyree Gill is by far you know
what's it like to cover Tyreke Hill do
you think amazing made a noise yes yes
rhythm for me I just tried to be
physical with them
you can do is kind of slow him down try
to match his routes that they run the
craziest routes in Casey man this year
an like a shallow shallow will homie and
that's never been like that never is
very much so it looks like it's a
shallow cross yeah okay so he's on one
side of the field you're with him yes
you're trying to trail him yeah anyway
or cover him from a trail position yeah
man zero okay okay so he's it looks like
he's just gonna keep running across the
field mitts it just turns up like a
wheel round yes and that's what Andy
Reid does man he's able to drop the
craziest routes for these guys and they
have the speed enough to for those guys
to get the protection get the blocking
and still run his playground routes well
and it's interesting you mentioned again
Chris Harris jr. and they're just show
the offensive line needs to block long
enough for somebody even as fast as
Tyree killed to run a route like that
exactly or you got 15 back there buying
some time himself you got double that so
you got the bomb time and they get that
they got a solid offensive line the
cheese and then also with the speed
receivers so I just think they're just
very tough man oh I don't see a team
right now that can only knock them off
as Ravens and the only reason why I say
the Ravens can't knock them off is
because they have three corners really
four if you add in Brandon Carr with
them because he can do all the things
too but they they have the four corners
that could match up with Casey and then
the pass rusher so that's one reason why
I think they're the only team I cannot
come well the good thing for Kansas City
is you know in taking on the Ravens is
that the factor of I didn't know Lamar
was that fast then that big and that
talented cuz they've never faced him
before that's gone Kansas City has twice
meet him twice once last year once
already this year who without Peters
that's true Marcus he's that much of a
difference maker you got four legit
corners now to where you can't really
you can't pick on anybody you know what
I mean and then they have the password
so I think adding him they're kind of
similar to how our defense was 2015
with the three corners I think that's
the only way that you can kind of slope
at my homes down and then have somebody
like Vampiro Thomas why didn't the
Earl's that girl's whole thing
oh yeah there's no doubt about that so
um you like the Chiefs to win the
Superbowl you have them win it all
Christmas
give me your Super Bowl that I can't win
the Super Bowl why is that because you
brought by paparazzi now I'm out I'm not
host talking to death run everything
guys in the media talking about this
game I could never say that Caesar gonna
win it well I'll never do that okay so
then who's coming out of the NFC I'll
say 49ers why do you like them they're
defense man I got the best deal on I
think um and then they run the football
so I'm gonna go with the 49ers run the
football great defense okay 49ers versus
Ravens then first of all okay and then
who do you got to win all that I got
both more you do the offense second day
you haven't talked about offense pretty
much at all here I know your defensive
gun office
you did you did grant me that how does
how his offense I mean pardon me how is
whether do you think in effect something
cuz again Mike del two foes weather
report is coming up that's one way for
me to tease the flopsweat that's about
to hit but also it's supposed to be
pretty darn nasty in Baltimore on
Saturday night what do you think about
that I think that hell's Baltimore
because they want to run the football
anyway Henry's a monster now you don't
want it that walk me through a bit in a
business decision with somebody like
Derek Henry and somebody like you in
five eleven as you pointed if I'm if I'm
the Titans I'm running I'm running
outside to the corners on the Ravens
if I see one little thing is there a
little they have
well Humphreys is a great tackler hmm
but Jimmy and Peter's versa Henry I
might have to go with Henry we'll take
the business decision I'm running
outside Henry Henry you that's what
you're doing
oh yeah and if it's raining like cats
and dogs that could be very helpful for
Tennessee to and then I'm given AJ Brown
the ball to a lot what do you like about
him he's just physical man I don't think
I don't think I've seen a receiver
stronger since I'm mentally
like other than Hilma DK Lord everybody
AJ Brown like he's like a running back
playing receiver mm-hmm and he's real
strong so I could see that could be a
potential problem for the Ravens - you
mentioned DK Metcalfe that guys yes yeah
I don't know how these guys hit McCord
in a sudden I don't know how they didn't
go first round top ten Peaks Sutton's
pretty amazing huh oh yeah yeah
Ryze beasts good to see you here before
I let you go Chris Harris jr. comm /
foundation is how that you can check
things out of what you are up to in
terms of your philanthropy
you are Walter Payton Man of the Year
candidate a couple years ago
congratulations on that that's amazing
to do and you got a kid two girls for
girls yeah oh my gosh
whoa that's a lot a sturgeon all the
time man yeah all the time I get great
patience for girls yeah okay
for babies in search of Chris Harris the
third no pressure thanks for joining
Chris Chris Harris jr. on both Twitter
and Instagram stay in touch as you're
going through the agent period when you
sign somewhere and we call oh I got you
man are you gonna be coming down to
money as well all right we'll be down
there too
I'll look forward to seeing you yeah
that's Chris Harris jr. right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app